[Music]
we may never know what's nudging or
Cloud objects out of orbit
but it's not the only mystery out there
we still don't know where the solar
system ends fighting the edge of the
solar system helps us with a bigger
problem of understanding the solar
system as a whole how do you know when
you have the whole solar system until
you found the edge
maybe the biggest mystery of all is that
our sun has too much stuff it's
wandering the cosmos with more than its
fair share it's possible our son is a
thief that robbed its sisters and
brothers in a cosmic womb
but that extra stuff could be our ticket
out when the sun turns up the heat on us